gainsbourg que nous retrouvons
maintenant je peux le faire moi si vous
voulez un essai y jeter essaye bombe à
givet
j'avoue
fait boutabout mes poumons
je n'avais même plus rien du tout dans
le caisson
e
vous plaît
en fumant que france
[Musique]
marc duret
confiant
et tu nous excuse je tiens tu étais pas
là on a fait ce qu'on pouvait parce que
on est un autre problème
oui la marseillaise alors à quoi bon la
marseillaise ta marseillaise ne plaît
pas absolument tout le monde aux armées
et je vais être présenté le général but
there voilà des rouges
jésus gerald but there qui avait
quelques mois de bi parfaitement si je
vous entends une seule fois chanté un
bond de la marseillaise je vous fous
autres outils soient pas faites moi
confiance bon parfum écoute toute façon
tu peux chanter autre chose ouais bon
c'est pour beaucoup de nos vieilles
canailles c'est une création pour
l'émission de serge gainsbourg vous
pouvez rester là géré le baiser à chaud
contrôle
[Musique]
et
très contente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien pour attendre
j'aurais bien tu avais toujours trop
court
[Musique]
le présenter ma femme était partie avec
je te soutenir dans des hôpitaux
mais je sortirai fait sentir ont fusé
[Musique]
vitres des mois d'hiver
[Applaudissements]
très bien mon petit gars c'est très bien
prendre quatre jours quand même
[Musique]